[Musique]
et ses joues belga
3 mark s
sébastien 36 ans vient de monter une
petite affaire aux portes de paris à
montrouge chanter
des plats cuisinés à emporter un rictus
la boisson
sébastien débute sa journée aux aurores
et finit à 23 heures dans la
restauration c'est toujours toi tu
gauche pour se bourrer maintenant elle
n'a pas le temps
ce qui lui laisse peu de temps pour
gérer les livraisons la paperasse et ses
comptes en banque
entre deux clients chantre effectué un
virement parce que je suis obligé de le
faire
de gérer mon administratif sur mon
téléphone j'ai accès à tous une banque
en ligne donc c'est simple c'est rapide
ça correspond à mon planning amant il y
a deux ans sébastien hésite à quitter sa
banque de quartier pour un établissement
entièrement en ligne aujourd'hui il ne
regrette rien j'étais dans une banque
traditionnelle ça me coûter 350 euros
par an de frais bancaires pour avoir une
carte et un compte chez eux aujourd'hui
ma banque en ligne ne coûte rien je
citerai toutes mes opérations à distance
et auquel cas si j'ai besoin je peux
appeler sur les employeurs d'horaires
beaucoup plus large que ça demande un
conseil compétent et qui va traiter mon
opération si je ne peux pas la faire à
distance je te faire gagner surtout les
portes ces dernières années le paysage
bancaire français se métamorphose la
plupart des établissements traditionnels
tiennent le marché depuis près d'un
siècle
mais aujourd'hui ils font face à de
nouveaux acteurs prêts à dépoussiérer le
secteur
aujourd'hui 4 millions et demi de
français ont leurs comptes dans des
banques exclusivement en ligne comme
boursorama bforbank oui ng et ce n'est
pas tout de nouveaux établissements
appelée neo banques apparaissent chaque
jour comme n 26 révolus ou encore max
qui n'a pas quatre ans d'ancienneté qui
se cache derrière ces nouveaux
établissements ces banques permettent
elles vraiment de faire des économies
donc les frais bancaires par an en
france et 200 euros tous les ans chez
boursorama c'est moins de 10 euros dont
vous avez une économie juste sur la
partie banque au quotidien votre carte
de crédit vos chéquiers votre compte
courant qui est divisé par 20 c'est
simple c'est un modèle économique
différent et le client et gagnent en
pouvoir d'achat l'objectif de cette
banque en ligne est d'atteindre plus de
4 millions de clients en 2023
ces chiffres donnent le vertige et des
idées à d'autres investisseurs de plus
en plus donné aux banques apparaissent
difficile de s'y retrouver si simple
rapide des finances n'ont jamais été
aussi bien organisée la plus connue est
n 26 avec 2 millions de clients en
france mais cet établissement n'offrent
pas les mêmes services que les banques
traditionnelles
impossible d'obtenir un prêt immobilier
par exemple quels sont les statuts de
ces nouveaux établissements
ont-ils les mêmes garanties que les
banques traditionnelles pas forcément
quand on est consommateur il faut
vérifier le statut de l'établissement si
c'est d'un établissement de crédit
aucune banque ou c'est un établissement
de paiement ou de mode électronique si
c'est un établissement de crédit ce
qu'on appelle une vraie banque entre
guillemets
et on est garantie d'avoir de récupérer
100 milles jusqu'à 100000 euros de ces
fous qui compte garantie à 100 mille
euros en cas de faillite et toujours
plus de services il ya dans le monde un
nouvel acteur qui se créent tous les
mois pour proposer du service financier
de banque au quotidien plutôt autour du
paiement on sait pas encore la manière
dont ils vont évoluer en terme de
rentabilité de profitabilité ya une
réelle interrogation sur dans quelques
années combien d'acteurs resteront parmi
les néo banques on trouve green got un
établissement de paiement qui prend soin
de la planète c'est le défi un peu fou
que s'est lancé mode caillou du haut de
ses 27 dans
l autre monde très contente de vous voir
en drap au niveau des investissements
est ce qu on a des accords pour m'a pris
mais j'ai une grille fine on va
aujourd'hui 21 mille clients ont décidé
d'apporter leur confiance à la jeune
entrepreneuse merci à vous toutes et
tous et puis un très vite parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on le sait que
trop peu mais son argent dans les
banques traditionnelles bah il permet de
financer les énergies fossiles dont le
pétrole le gaz le charbon et moi je fais
partie d'une génération qui essaye de
faire très attention à son impact sur
l'environnement et je me suis rendu
compte que mbaye avait pas de solution
pour bat pour nous pour mettre notre
argent ouvert en fait pour faire en
sorte que notre argent ne financent plus
à l'énergie fossile mais finances ce qui
va avec nos valeurs c'est à dire plutôt
les entreprises de la transition bas
carbone
mot de garantie de réelles placements
vers et rien qu en utilisant la carte
bancaire le client protège
l'environnement vous avez avec nous un
impact au quotidien puisque à chaque
fois que vous payer les frais que le
commerçant paye que vous payez par carte
nous les redirige vers des associations
notamment par exemple la cession de
dépollution du plastique dans les océans
on achète aussi des hectares de forêt
primaire au brésil pour les sauver de la
déforestation et on développe des
projets d'énergie renouvelable
que ce soit les établissements en ligne
des néo banque verte ou pas la
concurrence est rude pour les banques
traditionnelles
68% des français seraient prêts à faire
de ces nouveaux acteurs en ligne leur
banque principale
[Musique]